through.
Perfect. So, here's the plan. Today, I'm
going to be live all day,
uh,
minus breakfast and dinner from now
until probably like 8:00
p.m. Try to get a minimum of 10 hours
streamed in. Um, we're going to try to
really clean
up all of our training code for next
release. And I think that
today compared to yesterday, uh, we're
actually going to start looking at more
of the features that we currently have
in place and deciding which ones
actually matter uh, and which ones
don't. So, pretty much anything that I
haven't used in months, uh, we will just
drop. And there are a few things that I
want to try out. I want to try out this
distributional thing really quick. I
think I might have been a little
overeager to start on this yesterday.
But, uh, since I got a little bit of
progress in on it, I think I'm going to
spend just we'll probably give this like
the first hour, hour and a half today.
And if I make any progress, I make some
progress. If I don't, I don't. And uh
yeah, we will just continue from
there. The first thing that I want to
do, take a look at uh this run here is
doing quite
well. We will see how this does when it
finishes. It's going to take quite a
while. And then
next I want to take a look at the
distributional Q-learning
this. Now it's not going to be one to
one because this is for Q-learning.
I believe they have the algorithm
definition
here. So this is a very
simple
distribution. They're just saying that
you pick a minimum and a maximum value.
You bucket your value function into n
intervals uniformly over
that. And then you take softmax uh over
the outputs of each value head in order
to get the probability of being in each
bucket. Now how do they actually sample
this thing? I'd like to
know. Okay. Using a discrete
distribution poses a problem. The
Bellman
update and our
parameterization almost always have
disjoint
supports. Okay, I haven't seen enough of
their math for that, but we'll come back
to
this. It would seem natural to minimize
the Werstein
metric between these which is also
conveniently robust to discrepancies in
support. In practice, we're typically
restricted to learning from sample
transitions which is not possible under
the Werstein
loss. Instead, we project the sample
Bellman update onto the
support effectively reducing the Bellman
update to multiclass classification.
policy. Given a sample transition, we
compute the Bellman
update reward plus discounted ZJ for
each atom Zj. Okay, so this isn't what I
was thinking. And then we distribute its
probability to the immediate neighbors
of of this H.
Okay, this is not what I was thinking
about or this is not how I was thinking
about
it, but I think it gets simpler in the
on policy case.
Anyways, the E component of the
projected update is
Okay. So this is
just reward plus
discounted
this this is the bucketing operation. So
this is them just doing really annoying
fancy floor ceiling stuff. But this is I
think that this is just them bucketing
the value function here.
Okay, so it's good that I found this.
They actually need like 51 buckets.
That's a lot.
The fact that this doesn't work at all
on sequest until you go to 51 is very
sketchy.
Yeah. I don't understand what this thing
is doing here though at the
short. Okay. So let's see the output of
this
thing. Okay. So it's n times the number
of atoms.
And that gives you the
value uh it gives you like this
discretized value for each predicted
action which is going to be different
from what we do in the online
case. Okay. Okay. And now here we have
we have potentially what we're looking
for.
PMFS. Okay. So this is the probability
mass function for each action is what
this
is. And then this
uh this is going to only return the
probability for the action that you
actually take I
believe which is good because that's how
we're going to do it in online case
anyways
um or on policy case anyways. So we
should be really easily able to figure
this out from here. So this is just our
value function output softmax of our
value function output right here.
And then they do next
atoms. Yeah. Now we have to figure out
this mess here.
So we have delta
Z target networks of one minus target
network atoms of
H. Let's figure that
out. I think this is the
delta atoms.
have. Register buffer. Okay, here it's a
lin space right here. So this is
literally just going to be uh the step
delta. So if it's like 0 one or 0.5 1
1.5 and then it's just
0.5. And then what are we doing here?
We're going to
also? Oh, these are arguments.
Yeah, that's
interesting. Ah, but they just set these
to like big
values. Okay, so those are just
constants. If there if that's all it is,
then that's actually not that
bad. That's not that
bad. I thought it was going to have to
be some weird dynamic
Now, the thing that's a little sketchy
here, right, this
is there's going to be a difference here
between the Q-learning version and our
on policy
version. So let's see what we have so
far. We get the probability distribution
over actions.
Oh, this
is yeah so this is this doesn't depend
on this at all. So this is just this
next Adams thing
is just for every possible uh value that
you could have rewards plus discounted
projection. This still doesn't depend on
this at all.
And we actually we don't get we don't
depend on this at
all until
here. So all this is building the
targets I guess
right? All of this is just building the
targets.
becomes I believe this is just a
categorical Huh?
Okay. So you get your action here and
then the loss
is your
actions or your
log. This is your action log
props. I'm pretty sure this is just
cross entropy.
Yeah, I'm pretty pretty darn
sure. So, this is just your action
probability or action log props. It's a
cross entropy from your action
logs to whatever they've decided this uh
target PMF action index is. So, all of
this is just computing an index. Um
there's nothing fancier going on that I
can see.
So if we can figure out how they're
computing an index and how we modify it
specifically
This building was specifically uh
constructed to
avoid having
uh sun glare.
But my table is
Okay. So, what are they doing here?
They're
delta. Who wrote this code? I wonder is
this Costa's
So, it's a little confusing because
these are out of order
here, but they are just
clamping this like discounted reward
thing between the min and the max.
transformation. I think they're
splitting it between two adjacent
buckets or something here.
Ah, wait. Is this too
hot? L of
I.Long. Okay. I don't understand this
transform here.
normalizing.
Wait, you're This is not depending on
next PMFs at all,
right? Yeah. No, this does not depend on
next PMFS
uh at all.
It does depend on the rewards. So you're
using the rewards to construct the
targets. You're doing this like
normalized
uh this reward minus discount value
whatever. This is a
norm. And then you clamp this.
You're getting two integers out of this.
The floor and the
ceiling, like previous bucket, next
bucket, something like
operation. I'm having difficulty
figuring out what the heck they're
doing.
Do you need to do this? Do they have
ablations?
uh accepted with a way higher mean
score. Uh but their median was correct.
I actually don't know if we should
really even do this right now because
like does this make sense outside of the
off policy context? You learn the
distribution
You don't know the action yet, right?
It's not action
conditioned. I think that the smartest
thing to do with this given that there's
actually like some complexity here and
I'm not just implementing it one to one.
that would have to be a modified version
for uh on
policy. I think we just stash this for
now.
And I mean we see here though that the
way I was thinking about uh P30 is
completely
different from this
ridiculously Yeah. And then the way this
is the version of P3 I had in mind would
become ludicrously expensive as well
because this is now
predicting. I mean honestly this alone
is probably already somewhat
expensive. Yeah. I don't want to just go
do this wrong and like conclude that
this doesn't work because there's
actually like a pretty non-trivial
modification. I think that this should
be like on the top of the stack for
after the update. Uh is this is
something that I should look at here.
But like the the thing is that this is
going to require quite some modification
because like this is going to
essentially require me to decide or to
figure out the whole on policy versus
off policy split that happened with what
most of what DeepMind did and most of
what OpenAI did in like late 2010s early
2020s.
Um so I think that's going to be part of
the next research
segment. So, I don't think it makes
sense to spend like another hour on this
to do that. Here's what we're going to
do. We're going to just remove all P30
stuff for now.
later. Okay, we're at 1294
lines from that.
Uh we still have the V
trace experiments to
do. So those will actually have to do
the experiments on. And then there's the
question of can we get Diane to do
anything as
well. Let me see what are the key
questions we have to answer in order to
like
really get this thing to work.
Project name, please. This is Puffer
Lib. All my stuff is at puffer AI.
Whoops, not this one.
Puffer.ai. And we have ultra high perf
reinforcement learning M. You can play
them in your
browser. You can take over. You can
watch. This is me playing. I hit control
here. This guy will now be playing. We
have everything from like simple arcade
games like this miniature version of
OpenAI
5 and lots in
between. This is really a comprehensive
effort to fix everything wrong with
reinforcement
Mult benchmarking normalized for I did
that.
um let's see sampling
methods or batch or
replay form
clip flags.
Did I miss
anything? What other like options are
there? So, there's like this Vray
So like the difficult thing here is some
of
these get rid of this.
some of these. Um, we we want to run
like a bunch of experiments prior to
release on
these. There's a clip value loss and
there's normalized advantage. These two
else? We can do perf stuff on AM and
distributed today. That's a pretty easy
one to
conclude. Um the J vtrace puff advantage
that will be experiments.
Diane will be we need to run some
experiments. Off policy has never
worked.
Did you manage to get yesterday's stuff
working? Uh, the PyTorch stuff I did.
Yeah. The distributional stuff that I
started towards the end, I looked at
again this morning. It's more
complicated than I thought and it's
going to be like that's going to end up
being a multi-day thing. And I think
that it makes more sense to do that once
I have this release done as part of my
next effort, which is going to be a lot
of algo side stuff.
What about this target kale? This is
like something that it seems like we
should use but don't,
I kind of just want to like get rid of
all the options and flags here. I don't
want this to be like, oh yeah, you have
the options to do whatever. Like this
should just be the best set of things
that works. That's it.
Done. And like anything that a question
comes up, we will test
it and we'll figure it out definitively.
Okay, so we still have this working.
1271 lines, 3 million steps per second
um I think we can't do compile yet. We
should be able to do AM though.
So, uh, this still trains, but did it do
anything?
32. Okay, so I must have messed this up
at some point.
obviously. The backward
pass right here.
And we can actually check um we can
check dev branch to make sure we do this
right.
Okay. So, there is something
here. Um, what we should do
though here, we're going to save this
So, um, automatic mix precision is
supposed to just be faster. It's
supposed to just work everywhere.
Um, it's very possible though that there
is something screwy with small models
with it just being slower. But it's also
possible that there's like some weird
backend set and that I've just been
doing it wrong. So that's what we're
going to figure out
today and figure out if this is
valuable, if this should be an always
enable or if there should be uh a
toggle.
So, here's your float 32 training. This
should work.
and actions has a D type and this has
its own DT type. Cool.
runs. Okay, this still runs. It's nice
and
fast. Float
16. All tensors must be float 32.
Lovely.
sketchy. Okay, so maybe I can't store it
like this just yet.
We should still be able to make it
faster. If this works, if this works
well, then I will consider
uh making the
kernel support multiple D
types. Okay, so it's definitely slower.
So, let's see if it trains
stable. Get out of here,
Okay, so this does still
train potentially a very small
drop. Maybe not at
all. Yeah, it's about on par. Uh but it
is slower.
Now if I run with float
16 it is still
slower. Is it stable
though? Seems to
be. Uh let's see if we're actually doing
what we expect
actually Yeah, this is float 16. Okay,
so this is doing what we
Running out of shared memory somehow
here.
Ah, there we go. So, this was
actually screwing with something it
seems.
What are you building? I am working on
Puffer Lib. This is ultra high
performance reinforcement learning
library. We have lots of demos on
puffer.ai. It's all open source and I
stream all the dev
I'm curious if Bflat now gets faster all
of a
sudden. Now see, so Bflat is still
slow. Bloat is still slow.
Is that expected? I don't think that
should be expected.
right. Okay. So this is a little bit
faster. Not
though. It's a pretty
disappointing difference though for uh
going to 16
bit. Oh, hang on. Now, do we see the
speed up from
Bflat? Yeah, no, we do see this speed up
from Bflat now,
right? Okay. So that's actually worth
considering. It's
small about
10%. But it's
there. And that should let us optimize
other stuff more, right? Because
now No, we actually have very little
overhead on this either way.
I think neural link on discord has done
quite some research on precision
stuff RL discord discussion discord
maybe you could answer some
questions the like the old big RL
discord is that still active
I guess the main question would
be how much relative to what it has
been. Yeah. I I guess the main thing is
like
We see the speed up uh only on the
larger models and it's way less than we
would
expect I
think. And it's not like we
see Yeah, it's not like there's
additional MISK time or anything.
float
16 or let's just do float 16.
up. Okay, that's something, right?
Yeah, now that's a reasonable speed
up. So, yeah, we have these casts in
here. So, you have to be very careful
with your casts.
two. Now we're getting the expected perf
improvements at least not the well not I
wouldn't say the expected but we're
getting something
substantial and we get most of it with
be load as
So now we see that this is that this is
a
thing and we try it on like snake
So worth
using.
Um, we probably want to default this
based on model
size, I would guess.
I'm trying to think why it should be
slower. It's just like there's extra
cast and
stuff. It could be worth putting all the
buffers into this format.
Oh, interesting. The learning path got
slower. You see
still
slow. So it's not the scaling
What if I do just
uh just the inference?
Now, what are we
at? 25 22 23
comparable. It doesn't help now, but it
doesn't hurt either.
Yeah. So, you actually you do want it on
the backward
pass, but for whatever reason, it's
worse with Snake and with the smaller
models in general.
It can't be the comms because Breakout
doesn't use comms.
marginal. I'm trying to think if there
are any other M's I could play with for
this.
a new
meta. Does that work
segments. Now we have the slightest
annoyances. Lovely.
Yeah, I just needed this for an extra
test, an extra test M because this is
like a very slightly larger model.
and then nothing
here.
interesting. Oh, this has MPF issues.
I
see. That shouldn't have end issues. So
that's weird.
Yes. So float 16 actually does help
though.
So yeah, that's this is what I was
looking for,
right? Does anybody know what LLM people
do these days?
Okay, so they're quantized. They're
still trained on this.
Okay. I had thought that maybe people
had gotten lower precision training to
work by now.
FP16 non-tens tensor core has especially
high throughput.
I really would like to know why there is
a perk
difference. Um because it makes it very
difficult to benchmark
stuff. Like I'd really rather not have
to have float 16 at all if I can get
around it.
difference. I wonder if it's hardware
dependent.
same unless something is getting cash
weirdly,
right? But it would have to be doing
this in every single one, which is
errors. So there's Pong. Pong is
ridiculously fast. 4.7 4.8 Donate
slightly. That could just be the
additional data cast though.
I mean, I guess it's something like the
cast has to be unoptimized or whatever
because you do get the performance in
bigger models.
for bigger models. The B float and the
float is about the same as well. Right?
If I do like neural MMO
3, well, I've already tested this. It's
it's about the
same. So, I don't even really think we
want to mess with FP16 as much.
guess? I don't really think we want to
guess at stability
issues being like from
Well, how hard is it to write your
kernel with FP16?
it also. Maybe we don't have to do it in
place.
Okay, maybe I don't have to write custom
kernel here. Maybe we'll do here. Let's
do
this. Move this for now. I know what
we're going to do. Oops. Is it uh 9:51?
Okay. Lost track of time. I'm
uh I'm uh I will be back right after
breakfast. Uh and then we will finish AM
and we will keep optimizing this stuff.
So thanks
folks. Uh puffer.ai for all the things.
Go to the GitHub to help us out. Uh come
join us on Discord if you want to get
involved with dev. And I will be back.